los manifestantes salen a las calles en
todo Irán su ira se dirige contra un
grupo la policía de la moral
la unidad está señalada de la muerte de
Masha mini de 22 años por no llevar
correctamente el jillab su muerte ha
puesto en el foco la lucha en Irán
contra lo que se conoce como el mal y
Jack una lucha tan antigua como la
revolución islámica de 1979 desde
entonces la policía de la moral ha
adoptado varias formas su última
expresión es la guste sharp o patrulla
orientación una fuerza creada en 2007
muchos de sus agentes proceden de la
basic una unidad paramilitar de la línea
dura
el grupo que ha sido apodado como la
policía de la moda de líder supremo se
encarga de acabar con la vestimenta no
islámica esto incluye asegurarse de que
las mujeres se cubran el cabello y
lleven ropa larga y holgada para
disimular su figura los agentes también
persiguen a los hombres que llevan
peinados occidentales y reprenden a los
que practican la contaminación acústica
y la conducción insegura en virtud de
las reformas que se llevaron a cabo en
2016 los patrulleros de la moral solo
pueden denunciar a quienes no respetan
las normas a agentes de la policía que
decían que otras medidas deben tomarse
pero en el caso de marsha Mini los
patrulleros la detuvieron y la llevaron
a custodia murió en el hospital tres
días después los diputados critican
ahora al grupo por la muerte de aminy un
legislador modo en odín saety pide que
se elimine la unidad y se cierre del
todo No es la primera vez que la policía
de la moral iraní es objeto de críticas
durante las elecciones presidenciales de
2009 los candidatos reformistas pidieron
en vano su disolución